This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1898, China granted a 99-year lease to Great Britain for the areas across the harbor from the British-controlled island of Hong Kong. But SMAC in the middle of that territory, known as Kaolun, was an enclave that wasn't included in the lease. A place that would at least officially still be controlled by the Chinese. It was a large fort built decades earlier to put a check on British expansion, but it evolved into something very, very different. This was the first photo that I saw of it. Why don't you start describing it because it's a little... I haven't. Yeah, photo that I saw of it.
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。1898年，中国将香港岛英国控制区对岸的土地租借给英国，租期99年。但在该领土的正中间，也就是被称为九龙的地方，有一个不在租借范围内的飞地。这个地方至少在名义上依然由中国控制。这是一座几十年前建造的大型堡垒，旨在遏制英国的扩张，但它后来演变成了一个非常、非常不同的地方。这是我看到的关于它的第一张照片。你为什么不开始描述它，因为有点……我还没看过。是的，我看到的关于它的照片。
Why don't you start describing it? Because it's a little, I haven't. Yeah, taking it in yet. OK. The first analogy that that's brings into my mind is it looks a little bit like the, the Borg cube from Star Trek. Ha, ha, ha. It's a city block. And we're not looking at a neighborhood that's nestled in a city.
你为什么不开始描述它？因为它有点，我还没……是的，还在琢磨。好吧。它让我想到的第一个类比是，它看起来有点像《星际迷航》里的博格方块。哈哈哈哈。这是一个城市街区。我们看到的并不是一个坐落在城市里的社区。
Like we're looking at a Borg cube that is in the middle of nowhere. There's skyscrapers behind it, but the demarcation between this neighborhood and everything else is staggering. That's my friend Nick Vanderkulk from the program Love and Radio showing me photos. He was the first person who told me about this place. It became known as Calune Walled City. And even though the walls eventually came down, its name was still appropriate. There was no mistaking the boundaries between it and the rest of Hong Kong. The edges became a wall of 13-story high-rises overlooking a comparatively sparse squatters
就像我们看到一个位于荒郊野岭的博格方块。它后面有摩天大楼，但这个社区与周围一切之间的分界线是惊人的。那是我的朋友尼克·范德库尔克，来自节目《爱与广播》，他当时在给我看照片。他是第一个跟我提起这个地方的人。它后来被称为九龙城寨。尽管城墙最终被拆除了，但这个名字依然贴切。它与香港其他地区之间的界限毋庸置疑。边缘变成了一堵13层高的建筑高墙，俯瞰着相对稀疏的违章建筑
village. Buildings evolved organically, growing tendrils of bridges, pipes and wires that encroached on other buildings, until the city turned into a single, giant organism. Because it was in this legal nomads land, not under British jurisdiction, but pretty much ignored by the Chinese authorities, it became a magnet for the displaced in the marginal. Thousands of people moved there after war with Japan broke out of the thirties, and even more moved there after the Republic of China went communist. It attracted gangsters, drug addicts, sex workers, refugees, and it also drew a lot of average people from all over China who needed cheap rent and saw opportunity. Calune Wall City was at its height the densest place anywhere ever.
村落。建筑有机地生长，延伸出桥梁、管道和电线的卷须，侵占着其他建筑，直到整个城市变成了一个巨大的单一有机体。由于它处于这片法律的法外之地，不受英国管辖，却又基本被中国当局忽视，它成了流离失所者和边缘人群的磁石。30年代日本侵华战争爆发后，数千人搬到了那里；而在中华民国走向共产主义之后，搬去的人更多了。它吸引了黑帮、瘾君子、性工作者、难民，同时也吸引了来自中国各地、需要廉租房并看到机遇的许多普通人。九龙城寨在其鼎盛时期是历史上人口最稠密的地方。
It had a population density of about 3.2 million people per square mile. In comparison, Manhattan has a population density of about 70,000 people per square mile. That means that Calune Wall City was about 46 times as dense as Manhattan. So let me put that another way. If Manhattan wanted to get anywhere close to that kind of density, every man, woman, and child living in Texas would have to move there. I came across it very much by accident. I came around one corner and saw this structure that looked really different than everything else around it. That's Greg Gerard of Togifer. He lived in Hong Kong in the 80s and 90s. And that's when I first came aware of the
它的人口密度约为每平方英里320万人。相比之下，曼哈顿的人口密度约为每平方英里7万人。这意味着九龙城寨的人口密度大约是曼哈顿的46倍。换句话说，如果曼哈顿想要达到那种密度，所有住在德克萨斯州的男人、女人和小孩都必须搬到那里。我非常偶然地发现了它。我拐过一个街角，看到了这个结构，它看起来和周围的一切都非常不同。那是托吉特的格雷格·热拉尔。他在80年代和90年代住在香港。正是在那时，我第一次知道了
Waltz city and started photographing there. Its density was immediately apparent. Buildings have been built up against each other without any space between them. Each homeowner or each person who rented would build a different kind of caged balcony that would stick out a meter or two from their apartment. It was a way of opening up the apartment and getting more space and air and light.
城寨并开始在那里拍照。它的密度一目了然。建筑紧挨着彼此建造，没有任何空间。每个房主或每个租房者都会建造一种不同种类的笼式阳台，从他们的公寓凸出一两米。这是一种打开公寓、获得更多空间、空气和光线的方法。
I went for a first walk into one of the alleys and was immediately struck by what's overhead. And that's this tangle of electrical wires and garbage that had been thrown from the upper floors. TV and tennis all over the place, credible noises from the various manufacturing, metalwork, small kind of foundries, cotton mills, kitchens, furnaces,
我第一次走进其中一条小巷，立刻就被头顶上的景象震撼了。那是交织在一起的电线和从高层扔下来的垃圾。到处都是电视机和天线，来自各种制造业、金属加工、小型铸造厂、棉纺厂、厨房、熔炉的难以置信的噪音，
burning for barbecuing, pork or dock or whatever. Sensations underfoot as you go down some alleys, you know, into watery, squishy stuff. Watery, squishy stuff? Yeah, you know, stuff between buildings that you're walking on. I mean, I really don't even know what some of it was. All manner of sensory assault, really. Greg took a lot of photographs of the Walt City.
燃烧着用于烧烤的猪肉、鸭肉或其他什么。当你沿着一些小巷往下走时，脚下的感觉你知道，踩在水汪汪、黏糊糊的东西上。水汪汪、黏糊糊的东西？是的，你知道，建筑之间你踩着的东西。我的意思是，我甚至真的不知道其中一些是什么。各种感官的冲击，真的。格雷格拍了很多关于城寨的照片。
There's one, probably one of my favorites of his, of a temple. It's much shorter than the 13th story high rises around it. Over the temple is this huge metal grate that's there to keep trash off the roof. The lifestyle of living in the Walt City was to dispose of garbage by throwing it out your window. And so the temple built a big net above its roof and then it actually cussed beautiful shadow through all this trash. It allowed for a really interesting light to filter down through some of the bases in
有一张，可能是我最喜欢他的照片之一，拍的是一座寺庙。它比周围13层的高楼矮得多。寺庙上方是一个巨大的金属格栅，用来防止垃圾落在屋顶上。住在城寨的生活方式就是把垃圾扔出窗外处理。因此，寺庙在屋顶上方搭建了一个大网，然后它实际上在所有这些垃圾中投下了美丽的阴影。它让一些光线穿透进来，
the garbage almost like a tropical kind of canopy, except this one was made for refuge. That new voice you heard is Aaron Tan. Aaron is an architect from Hong Kong and wrote his master's thesis about the Waltz City. Any interview to a lot of people who lived there. The Waltz City was at his prime time during the 60s and 70s and there was also the same time where the great thinkers of architect like the Aki Grams, the Metabolos was talking about this kind of self-organizing structure, intelligent building thinking, all this thing are going on in the west, but not recognizing the
垃圾几乎就像一种热带树冠，只不过这个是为避难而建的。你听到的那个新声音是陈蔚。陈蔚是来自香港的建筑师，他的硕士论文写的就是城寨。采访了很多住在那里的人。城寨在60年代和70年代处于全盛时期，这也是建筑界的伟大思想家如阿奇格拉姆、代谢主义者谈论这种自组织结构、智能建筑思维的同一时期，所有这些事情都在西方发生，但却没有认识到
existence of the world city actually is doing that. So on the other hand, the world city in Hong Kong is growing by itself but without any architect working on it. So it's like the coexistence of two. One is very theoretical, one is something very real and they do not know the existence of each other until much later when in the late 80s, when Greg Gerard or in the early 90s, when we start to look at it and see that the amazing coexistence of this two thing during the same time. Because the walled city was virtually autonomous from both China and Britain, resistant of this two things during the same time. Because the walled city was virtually autonomous from both China and Britain, there wasn't a lot in the way of infrastructure.
城寨的存在实际上正在做到这一点。因此，另一方面，香港的城寨在没有任何建筑师工作的情况下自行生长。所以就像两者的共存。一个是高度理论化的，一个是极其真实的，在很长一段时间里，他们甚至不知道彼此的存在，直到80年代后期格雷格·热拉尔到来，或者90年代初我们开始审视它，才看到这两者在同一时期惊人的共存。由于城寨实际上脱离了中国和英国的自治，在同一时期抵御着这两者。因为城寨实际上脱离了中国和英国的自治，基础设施并不多。
There weren't any building codes obviously, and there wasn't any garbage collection either. Which is why people threw their trash at the window. The walled city gained a reputation as a sort of den of an equity. There were high levels of prostitution, gambling, organized crime, and for some reason there seems to be a lot of rampant unlicensed dentistry. But a kind of order did emerge. The triads who are sort of like the Chinese version of the mafia filled the power vacuum with its own rule of law. They made at least some attempts at hygiene.
显然没有任何建筑规范，也没有任何垃圾收集。这就是为什么人们把垃圾扔出窗外。城寨赢得了某种罪恶渊薮的名声。这里有高水平的不知廉耻的卖淫、赌博、有组织犯罪，而且不知为何似乎有很多猖獗的无证牙医。但某种秩序确实出现了。三合会，有点像中国版的黑手党，用自己的法治填补了权力真空。他们至少在卫生方面做出了一些尝试。
Trot gangs could get the trot addicts to clean up the up the streets and residents organizations popped up to settle disputes between neighbors. There was industry too, needle factories, fishball factories, textiles. There were restaurants and because this annotation wasn't great, they would kill your meal in front of you to prove that they weren't serving the spoil of meat. A lot of the electricity was pirated, Someone would tap a cable into the grid and run it over and across the buildings, and then an official would shut it off, then somebody would tap the grid again, lay a new cable on top of the dead one, and then that would get shut off and so on and so on. Eventually there were just so many cables running over and across
小偷帮派可以让吸毒者清理街道，居民组织如雨后春笋般涌现，以解决邻里之间的纠纷。这里也有工业，针织厂、鱼丸厂、纺织品。这里有餐馆，由于卫生状况不是很好，他们会当着你的面宰杀你的食物，以证明他们没有提供变质的肉。很多电力都是偷接的，有人把电缆搭到电网并拉到建筑群各处，然后官方把它切断，接着有人再次搭接电网，在旧电缆上面铺设新电缆，然后又被切断，如此循环往复。最终，有太多的电缆在
all the buildings, but the alleyways below were almost in total darkness. You cannot rely on what you see because you get lost right away, you know, but based on smell, you could better. Maybe that's a little poke here, and then there's another cluster of actually doing sugar and sweet. So actually relying on your smell, you can actually navigate through the city better. It was said that if you knew actually navigate through the city better." It was said that if you knew your way around the city's elaborate maze of catwalks, you could walk from one side to the other, without ever touching the ground. In the 70s and 80s, when the end of the new territory's lease was on the horizon, Britain
所有的建筑上方和穿梭其间，以至于下方的小巷几乎完全陷入黑暗。你不能依赖你所看到的，因为你马上就会迷路，你知道的，但凭着气味，你可以做得更好。也许这里有一点气味，然后是另一处实际上在制作糖果的聚居点。所以实际上依靠你的气味，你真的可以更好地在城市中穿行。据说，如果你熟悉
and China began to figure out what it meant for the future of Hong Kong. And part of that negotiation included the question of what to do with the Wallet City. After three quarters of a century of ambiguity from both countries, they finally agreed on a long eviction process. And in 1993, four years before Britain handed over control of Hong Kong to China, Calune Wald City was demolished. But the story of the Wald City does not end with its destruction. I'm Brian Douglas and I design the first draft of the Calune Wald City level in Call of Duty Black Ops.
城市复杂的猫步桥迷宫，你可以从一端走到另一端，而双脚永远不用落地。在70年代和80年代，当新界租约到期临近时，英国
Call of Duty is our first person shooter video game series. Normally you get into like an army situation where maybe you're in the middle of the street or you're up on the second story or something. But it's not a very vertically dynamic world most of the time except visually we never usually get to get up to those tall points. In other words, in most games like this the scenery is just scenery. You can't interact with most of the visual world that exists off the ground. Usually they're just there to make the world feel fleshed out and real. But with Calooon we was actually like, well let's go up there. A call of duty black ops is just one of many games to recreate the city.
和中国开始弄清楚这对香港的未来意味着什么。谈判的一部分包括如何处理城寨的问题。在两国长达四分之三个世纪的模棱两可之后，他们终于就一个漫长的驱逐过程达成了一致。1993年，即英国将香港控制权移交给中国四年前，九龙城寨被拆除了。但城寨的故事并没有随着它的毁灭而结束。我是布莱恩·道格拉斯，我设计了《使命召唤：黑色行动》中九龙城寨关卡的第一版草案。
It lives on in a kind of virtual memorial, except with way more gunfire. This is kind of a level builder stream because it provides opportunities that we don't normally get. In our first sequence, you can see sort of the liberties that it allowed us to take because if I needed to just make something really sort of crooked and awkward, it was just all like carte blanche because it really fit into the nature of the city. The doorways weren't necessarily the right size, or the hallways were a little center and they bend in the middle. Some of the ceilings were a little taller, where wasn't really fully developed and where wires coming off of it.
《使命召唤》是我们的第一人称射击视频游戏系列。通常你会进入某种军队场景，也许你在街道中间，或者在二楼什么的。但这绝大多数时候并不是一个垂直动态的世界，除了视觉上，我们通常不会到达那些高处。换句话说，在大多数这样的游戏中，风景只是风景。你无法与地面之外的大多数视觉世界进行互动。通常它们只是为了让世界感觉更丰满和真实。但对于九龙，我们实际上是想，好吧，让我们去那里。使命召唤黑色行动只是重新创造这座城市的众多游戏之一。
You could just imagine what you will for it and it was probably suitable. I played the walled city level, actually that's the lie. I watched a friend of a friend play because I probably would have died in the first two minutes. But anyway, it's clear that Brian and the other designers put a lot of thought into each location. For instance, a particular room might have a half-eaten meal on the table. There are these signs of a moment in someone's life. But even though the world is full of bad guys trying to shoot you, you come across almost no one who's actually living there.
它以一种虚拟纪念馆的形式生存下来，只是伴随着更多的枪声。这有点像关卡构建者的狂欢，因为它提供了我们通常无法获得的机遇。在我们的第一个序列中，你可以看到它允许我们采取的某种自由度，因为如果我只需要制作一些非常扭曲和笨拙的东西，那简直就是全权委托，因为它真的很符合城市的本质。门不一定是正确的尺寸，或者走廊有点居中并在中间弯曲。有些天花板高了一点，尚未完全开发，上面挂着电线。
It's easy to lose sight of the fact that this was a real living, breathing neighborhood. When you discovered that they were going to be tearing down, I mean, what did you think about that? You sort of knew it as a real neighborhood, and not just this sort of fantastical den of iniquity. Yeah, you know, quite mixed feelings. I mean, the place was completely unbelievable, and it was just this fantastic phenomenon.
你可以随心所欲地想象它，而且它可能很合适。我玩过城寨关卡，其实那是谎言。我看着朋友的朋友玩，因为我可能在前两分钟就死掉了。不管怎样，很显然布莱恩和其他设计者对每个地方都倾注了大量的心血。例如，某个房间的桌子上可能有一顿吃了一半的饭。这些都是某人生活中某一时刻的迹象。但尽管这个世界充满了试图射杀你的坏人，你却几乎遇不到任何真正住在那里的人。
This is Greg Gerard again, the photographer. At the same time, that civic-minded part of you knows that this canton shouldn't continue. It was a fire hazard, a hell of a hazard. It's one of those things that it fell between the cracks and grew there into this beautiful monstrosity. Aaron, the architect has a similar ambivalence.
人们很容易忽视这样一个事实：这是一个真实、充满活力的社区。当你发现他们要拆除它时，我的意思是，你怎么看？你把它看作一个真实的社区，而不仅仅是这种光怪陆离的罪恶渊薮。是的，你知道，感情相当复杂。我的意思是，这个地方简直让人难以置信，它就是这样一个奇妙的现象。
I do, for me, as from an architectural foil view, I was very sad to see it go, but when I interview with people 20 years later, I also get half-half kind of respond. As some say, all this place is smelly, it's bad, I'm glad that it's gone, so that now you see my new flat is much better. But there are some people have very good memory of the city. They miss the richness of the space inside, they miss the community inside, they miss the convenience inside that they can get things easily in the city.
这是摄影师格雷格·热拉尔。与此同时，你身上那个具有公民意识的部分知道这个城寨不应该继续存在下去。这是一个火灾隐患，一个该死的隐患。这是那些从缝隙中滑落并在那里长成这个美丽怪物的存在之一。建筑师陈蔚也有类似的矛盾心理。
So you do get this two kind of opinion, too. But for Aaron, there was a value in having it dismantled. As a graduate student, he got to observe the city getting taken apart piece by piece. For him, it was an autopsy, a way to see how the various pieces of the city all fit together. He was able to build an understanding about how cities function almost with their own will. And as an architect, Aaron learned to allow for this sort of organic self-determination into his projects. Tan now incorporates some lessons of Calune Walt City into his own work. Rather than planning everything to a T, he now looks for ways to allow the organic nature of a city
我有，对我来说，从建筑学的角度来看，看到它消失我很难过，但当我20年后采访人们时，我也得到了毁誉参半的回应。有些人说，这个地方太臭了，很糟糕，我很高兴它消失了，所以现在你看我的新公寓好多了。但有些人对这座城市有着美好的记忆。他们怀念里面空间的丰富性，怀念里面的社区，怀念里面的便利，他们可以在城市里轻易地买到东西。
to organize itself. We are not saying that this is a wonderful place. We are not trying to say that we want to duplicate this model because its existence is so unique position in history. You cannot recreate it. But in the only hand when you look at it, it has a certain quality in its performance as an urbanism. It performed well in a very restricted constraint that with lack of water, without electricity, they know how to organize themselves, you know how to deal with it. The trash, like I said, on one hand, they might see their malt trash, but on the other hand, they know how to organize the people inside to remove them, and even a postman inside know how to deliver the letters. So it is a kind of good alternative model for us to evaluate our design strategy.
所以你确实也有这两种截然不同的意见。但对陈蔚来说，拆除它是有价值的。作为一个研究生，他得以观察这座城市被一点一点地拆解。对他来说，这是一场解剖，一种了解城市各个部分是如何组合在一起的方法。他能够理解城市几乎是如何以自己的意志运作的。作为一名建筑师，陈蔚学会了在他的项目中允许这种有机的自我决定。陈蔚现在将九龙城寨的一些教训融入到他自己的工作中。他不再事事计划周全，而是寻找方法来让城市的有机本质
99% Invisible was produced this week by Nick Vanderkulk from the show's Love and Radio and Snap Judgment, with some help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Radeo Tapio from PRX There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
自我组织。我们并不是说这是一个美妙的地方。我们并不是想说我们想要复制这个模型，因为它的存在是历史上的一个如此独特的定位。你无法重新创造它。但另一方面，当你审视它时，它作为一种城市规划具有某种表现品质。它在非常严格的限制下表现出色，在缺水、无电的情况下，他们知道如何组织自己，知道如何应对。垃圾，就像我说的，一方面，他们可能会看到垃圾，但另一方面，他们知道如何组织里面的人来清理它们，甚至里面的邮递员也知道如何送信。所以这是我们评估设计策略的一个很好的替代模型。